STANDS IN THE WAY, A
WITH HACK CAN PAW. SIDE.
>> D
SATURDAY.
AND A SHOT,IT GOES OFF
EICHEL TRIED TO FEED IT THERE,
AND HARLEY GOT AWAY FROM THAT
HAKANPAA EARLIER, AND D. GOAL F
TEACH THEM TO PLAY.
HERE IS WITH TWO SECONDS
LEFT IN THE SECOND PERIOD, AND
THE
MANIPULATION OF THE STICK FOR
STEPHENSON W W
COULD SEND THEM IN POST GP WITH.
THEODORE, MISCOMMUNICATION WITH
AND BACK COME THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS
AND
VEGAS.
ACROSS, AND WHAT A SAVE! PAST
HIS OWN SHOT BLOCKER.
CAPTAIN, LEAVES IT FOR THEODORE,
AND BACKHAND, AND OETTINGER, THE
SAVE, C 1:05 AND STON REFLECTED
FRONT, OFF THE SIDE OF THE NET,
RTSON,
HEISKANEN, STEPHENSON, STONE AND
THEODORE FOR HINTZ, SAVE IN THE
PATIENCE BY THOMPSON TO HANG THE
GLOVE IN,
STOLEN BACK BY STEPHENSON, WIDE
TO THE NEAR THE SHOT OF
CHOICE.
ROBERTSON ON THOMPSON,
ESM RIGHT DOWN THE SEAM.
HE: THOMPSON IS